this is ugali made from Kenya staple
unga or maize meal like most Basics here
its price has gone up and because of
shortages it's not easy to find
evenings continue this way more
businesses will close we are facing a
lot of challenges
corruption foreign debt Rising inflation
and unemployment are big election issues
and all candidates have promised to
cushion households against the
increasing cost of living
four politicians are running for the
presidency David mawuri a lawyer and
Pastor George wajakoya a law professor
William Ruto Kenya's Deputy president
and raila odinga a former prime minister
but opinion poll suggests there are two
Front Runners
the current Deputy president who
describes himself as a hustler and hopes
his rags to Rich his story will resonate
with the poor
and odinga who's making his fifth bid
for the top job the veteran opposition
leader is the son of Kenya's first vice
president and enjoys the backing of
current leader Uhuru Kenyatta
it's an election some analysts say will
be hotly contested kikuyu is the largest
ethnic group in Kenya have no
presidential favorites this time however
both Ruto and odinga have chosen hikuyu
running mates in a country where ethnic
voting blocks are important a divided
kikuyu vote means a selection to go
either way
there are already claims and counter
claims of sabotage and vote rigging more
than a thousand people died in the 2007
elections what happens with Kenya's
geopolitical significance is that it
just that tension uh sort of begins to
to shake up the uh the stability of the
of the Great Hall of Africa and then the
larger East Africa so that's what and
there's a lot of international uh
organizations that are based here so
Kenya is very strategic from a global
perspective and that's what the
International Community is looking at
the business Community is basically just
sitting on the edge of their seats
trying to figure out whether this is
going to go peacefully or not
unlike some previous votes there's been
less pre-election violence Kenyans
generally have confidence in the
Judiciary many hope if the results are
disputed candidates will resolve their
differences in court and not the streets
Nairobi